we have worries actually with the great
garry kasparov one world champion
replaced by another two of the greatest
players in the history of the game here
in Zagreb Gary what is going on what
you've seen I mean you've seen a lot in
the history of chess watching what
Magnus is doing the black pieces 23
moves dismantling players he said I just
bluffed him but you know we got into a
dogfight what's going on explain this
yeah okay it was nice for Magnus TT to
say that but it's not about bluffing
it's about better understanding of the
game of chess you made these comments
that you know today you know many of
things we you know we took for granted
now they're not so clear so when we
watched computer games alpha 0 game so
we understand that you know it's it's
something that beyond our understanding
because machine goes you know just one
or two moves ahead so always just
recognizing new patterns so simply
what's happened in this game it's just
you know Magnus had a much deeper
understanding of the position so it's
and I you know just had quite a quick
word with him before in the room so 10
years ago we just you know quickly look
at the suppositions because when I play
chess after Bishop b5 I mainly play D 6
and I wasn't sure that take 1 to 6 BC
sixes so for white because black has in
a potential is two bishops and we
discuss things with f6 and d6 and and
mango said he was almost sorry now that
two bishops could give him just you know
in a very you know just potential strong
come to play and what's happening now
give him try to play you know
positionally I mean flighty to is
classic Howe she wants play Knight d4
that we play 92 but that's not the way
to play because it's justice
I mean Magnus sees the whole world well
you know even players of gearing caliber
they could see this or the fragment of
the board how's that possible
I mean he's making he's making him look
like a child nobody wins in 23 moves
like this and you say he's almost twenty
here he's been over 2800 look it still
you know is a world champion not just
not just because he's lucky just to have
a title I just sees he's there for
almost 10 years now
one rated player it's for many for many
things and one of them is a very deep
understanding of the game of chess again
yes the weak points but gnah czo the
opportunities what I can do so how can i
it's just it's again every element of
the position so there were many many I
mean you have a computer you could see
how many mistakes get made so it's not
just losing in 23 game it removes he's
just making this - serious mistake and
some inaccuracies but why did he made
all these mistakes and why he was not so
precise as it used to be because police
was unbalanced basically what man who's
did is just their Genesis translating
his joke into into serious statement is
that he created position that was highly
unbalanced and remember when we had a
verse conversation after d6 Giri was
what's happened because his position was
tool imbalanced so here he used to
certain a certain type of the positions
that he could study at home but now it's
everything goes of the preparation and
and he has to deal with so many factors
like you know comparing you know apples
and I don't know tomatoes so as this and
he failed he failed miserably and Magnus
was in a quickness turn on the spot you
know just you know like like you know
with animal instincts you noticed he
spotted this weakness you know he could
smell the blood and he went for kill
Gary you just described yourself in your
finest form it was going to come in
second place and you look at it he's
attacking with the black pieces with the
Sicilian with ferocity I mean there's no
look at the endgame he's just going
after them again it's it's before he
attacked he created conditions for that
attack and he create conditional attack
because Gary couldn't play it is
unbalanced position
so he's greatest decision was actually
to 26th you go for this and Allah's
position which machines did like for
black but again she was not faith
fighting the machine was playing another
human and he knew that Giri
you know just playing this new position
unbalanced position position that is
just here where you don't have this
clear positional sort of the
milestones so that's it's because Giro
is very good you know if you know just
doesn't he can do a little move suggest
you know here's my weakness I protected
witness h4 is a witness or not you know
so and black king is now unafraid but
who cares so that's it there's so many
things that you know that there are you
know that are very hard to combine and
compare because they're not you know
it's about you know unbalance King
technically white King is castle lacking
didn't castle but what King will be made
in in ten moves so let's see that's yeah
that's what makes a difference between a
very strong player and the world champ
you know you you world champions where
that's that title with pride rightfully
so what do you feel he is right now in
his play as you've seen him in his
finest form five years ago and now his
form now has he just gotten that much
better and will he break twenty-nine
hundred most likely most let's say he
deserves it but it's it's not it's not
because it's you know it's every every
every point will be more and more
difficult because don't forget every
loss brings him down without every drop
resume down look I used to to to to
finds kind of universe you know he's
just having you know my rating you know
100 100
were the average it's even 150 over the
average so it's it's it's a tough
challenge but look I think Magnus tries
those challenges so it's the in again
it's just numbers and numbers but he's
definitely you know if give his 2809
definitely 2900 so that's that he's
playing for the strengths whether he can
make it there it's still getting his
numbers are sometimes sometimes tough
but again that's team the way mine was
place you know and that's what makes me
really happy that you know it puts an
end the whole story over the chest is
dead yeah as long as you know you have
an appetite for fight as long as you
know you you you are eager to just to go
against this traditional understanding
so there's just I mean to play some
sharp openings you say the game could
end up in 23 moves and again Gary's not
you know just it's it's not a player in
our from opportunity this is one of the
top tier number four in the world right
now number four the world so and if
Magnus keep playing this way I'm sure
you will so this is it's just you know
will
you know we'll be really entertained and
that's what I'm looking for so it's
important for the game of chess so the
people are entertained and it's an and
everybody was saying you know let's stop
playing classical chess it's it's it's
it's irrelevant it doesn't make any
sense it does I know you have a plane to
catch whole family back in again this
this controversial one if you will what
is it gonna take you know a lot of us
believe you're the greatest player ever
to have such a chess piece at your
performances at least have shown that
sustained over so many years what's it
gonna take from Magnus for you to say
okay this guy
maybe he's passed me okay first of all I
always resisted you know the idea of
kicking up you know the one the best
player because can the only way to
compare the two players is to put them
against each other so technically we can
play now but is this it'll be a massacre
so I'm just you know and thinking about
a hypothetical battle Gary let's say
from 1989 and magnums 2019 again it
doesn't make any sense it's like
bringing Fischer from 1972 look he
definitely belongs to D to the greatest
of the great so is this I'm not today
I'm just pretty you know just it's
number one number two number three spot
but the way he dominates Chet's you know
you know just it reminds us of the
fitness of the three years of Bobby
Fischer in 1970 1972 it reminds of my
best year so and that's I think that's
enough already to you to recognize these
great contribution of game of chess and
you think what's most beautiful it's not
over
Rushmore of chess if you will the
pantheon of the gods we still you know
they're speaking about the the classical
chairs and and the threat to them look
at the games that played in the first in
the first round of brunches to Bobby
versus Nakamura Bobby Bobby is winning I
mean the end is just they play Queens
gambit this is the drawers opening look
what's happened so that's again so it's
very sharp and look at the even even
drama in the era of Kuryakin I mean
that's that's that's a hell of a draw so
it's the so it's it's a little fight so
this is it's it's I think it's very
important you know that during the
we know we could see that the again
they're all rumors about the end of
classical chairs they are just you know
they overstated thank you so you're
going yes when your fight
thanks for joining us and you will be
back you're probably absolutely yes so
Friday fans and it's just one moment
here while we say our goodbyes Gary
Kasparov is you know one of the greatest
ever live T of comments on who is a
player who's totally shown that he is
also one of the greatest of all time